bonjour bonjour
bonjour
sous le feu
l'avion français
il s'appelle romane oleksandr jaroslaw
ou encore consciente in ce sont des
joueurs de football ukrainien avec leur
entraîneur gurit yaroshenko ils viennent
d'arriver à poissy ils sont accueillis
ici à cause de la guerre en ukraine en
leur honneur le président du club de
football et le maire karl olive ont
organisé une cérémonie l'idée c'est
qu'ils assouplissent leurs patients qui
continue à jouer et puis moi et s'ils
ont une licence de moi et que dans trois
mois c'est la fin de la guerre je serai
le plus heureux des hommes on la mettra
dans l'avion on rappellera les billets
d'avion et on partira sûrement la larme
à l'oeil mais avec un gros sourire sous
ce qui me kim à lima - en tout cas la
première les actions que je mets en
place maintenant c'est de demander à
l'état et à la fédération française de
football d'accorder des licences
rapidement pour que ces jeunes ces
jeunes puissent jouer il évolue en
deuxième division ukrainienne ça va nous
faire du bien
[Musique]
footballeur professionnel de lipova
dolina club de deuxième division
ukrainienne ils se sont tout de suite
mis dans le bain un premier entraînement
avec les joueurs pisciacais évoluant en
quatrième division c'est une fierté
parce que l'on montre qu'on est là pour
aider les gens et que que le footsie
césar c'est partage ses envie d'aider
les autres qu'on se met à leur place et
c'est pas facile pour eux on vit à
travers les réseaux sociaux par ce qui
se passe pas à la télé on voit ce qui se
passe et c'est franchement pas évident
après nous sont pas apportées à notre
manière le fait est qu'ils puissent
venir s'entraîner avec nous et les
mettre dans les meilleures dispositions
disposition les gestes techniques sont
fluides les connexions entre les joueurs
paraissent naturelles malgré la
différence de langue français et
ukrainiens se comprennent
dans le langage du football il n'y a pas
besoin de traduire cet universel
le football c'est tout dans ma vie et je
suis très content de pouvoir m'entraîner
ici à poissy en france avec l'équipe
les joueurs ont une bonne qualité de jeu
un bon niveau on voit qu'il joue au
football depuis longtemps ils ont la
qualité technique et ils sont forts et
le coach pisciacais walid haïchour
propose même à son homologue ukrainien
d'animer une séance d'entraînement ce
lundi sera deux jours après le match et
c'est pas une idée n'est que samedi
nous
mixer